الشرطه الاخلاق في ايران تم حلها في خطوه
فسرت على انها رضوخ من النظام للشارع
المحتج المدعي العام الايراني لم يقدم
تفاصيل حول مستقبل شرطه الاخلاق او ما اذا
كان حلها سيكون بجميع انحاء البلاد وبشكل
دائم ام لا ليبقى مستقبل هذه القوه غامضه
السؤال الذي يطرحه الايرانيون هو هل سيذبح
هل هذه القوه خطوات اخرى مشابهه فكره او
فكره بحث ملف شرطه الاخلاق متداوله منذ
الايام الاولى بعد مقتل امين ليخرج نواف
في البرلمان ويعلن تشكيل لجنه تقصي حقائق
لتحديد سبب وفاه امين اضافه لما قد يترتب
على ذلك من تبعات على شرطه الاداب الصحفيه
والناشطه الايرانيه مسيح علي نجاد اعتبرت
ان الغاء شرطه الاخلاق مجرد بدايه لان
الايرانيه هو الايرانيين بداوا الاعتراض
على الحجاب الا وسيتبعه رفض المنظومه
الحاكمه كما يحدث في الشارع والمطالبه
بتغييرها
[موسيقى]
اذا فالمحتاجون باتوا ينادون بالاعتراف
بحريه الحجاب في ايران وليس الحجاب
الانساني فضلا عن طرح تساؤلات حول النظام
الحاكم او ما يطلق عليه الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الرد جاء من الرئاسه قبل اسبوع
حين قال محمد دقان نائب الرئيس الايراني
للشؤون القانونيه في مؤتمر صحفي انه من
المستحيل الاستفتاء على اصل النظام الحاكم
وحريه ارتداء الحجاب لاحقان اضاف ان اي
استفتاء محتمل سيجري بموافقه المرشد
وتصميد ثلثين وبالبرلمان وانه من المستحيل
تغيير نظام الجمهوريه كما ان حريه الحجاب
تتعارض مع مبادئ ايران بحسب وصفه
تزامن عقد الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي اجتماعا
مغلقا مع رئيس البرلمان محمد باقر قالباف
ليخرج المتحدث باسم الرئاسه البرلمان
قائلا ان الجزء الاساسي من النقاش تركز
على الاحوال المعيشيه والاقتصاديه واضاف
ان افضل طريقه لتحقيق الاستقرار هي
الاهتمام بالمطالب الحقيقيه للشعب على حد
قوله بشكل عام يرى مراقبون ان وسائل
الاعلام الرسميه الايرانيه بدات تتبنى
لهجه اكثر تصالحيه معبره عن رغبه في
التعامل مع مشكلات الشعب الايراني
[موسيقى]